all right well we are turning to our
weather here this sunday and into labor
day weekend sally we have some hot
weather coming so we have to prepare for
that right that's right what do you do
to beat the heat oh my goodness probably
stay inside in the air conditioning or
jump in the pool that's always a win
right that is a very good tip sasha of
course we remind you to please limit
your time
outdoors as much as possible and of
course drink plenty of water you know
the drill hopefully you enjoy from this
labor day weekend but as we mentioned we
will continue to increase those
temperatures quite a bit for the next
few days we do want to let you know that
heat will be the primary concern
starting around monday into your tuesday
and you want to make sure that if you're
going to be going outdoors do so in the
morning hours working out you want to do
it early morning avoid that 11 a.m start
your almanac will also show you for
today we increased five degrees warmer
than yesterday lows for tonight will be
of 81 degrees that record number behind
me 109. so back in 1977 we won't be
reaching out but we're four degrees away
from it outside right now plenty of
triple digits we're going to start with
our friends in summerlin with 100
degrees there downtown 102 green valley
103 for you right now and seven hills
105 for you right now checking out those
regionals it is very hot especially for
death valley eventually death valley you
could potentially reach
120 degrees for the next few days for up
99 degrees same goes for sandy valley
right now southwest radar we have that
ridge of high pressure it continues to
grow increase those temperatures keeping
us extremely dry and you can see that
excessive heat warning will kick in
tomorrow morning continuing all the way
until late tuesday potentially be
extended for one more day and we will
keep you posted if that changes
futurecast also showing you the return
of some moisture rolling in
for the second half of the week we could
potentially have some slight chances of
rain mainly impacting the higher terrain
as of now those chances pretty slim 15
chance on thursday and into your friday
wind speeds very calm conditions you can
see it there quiet out there this
holiday weekend expect those
temperatures to rise we do have that
heat warning in effect till tuesday and
tonight expect 81 degrees clear
conditions here's a look at your next
eight days we will be very close to that
record number of 108 or potentially
exceeding that record number by tuesday
set back in 1977 and then moisture
returns bringing us more clouds and
chances for rain back to you